blue a eu un petit c'est impossible
salut maranda
tu ressembles à ta mère
[Musique]
t'inquiète pas je te promets de la ramée
plus rien ne retient le pouvoir de la
génétique
nous avons commis une grave erreur
l'ofj de l'apocalypse s'est emballé
à
[Musique]
pour que notre monde survivre ce qui
compte c'est ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui
j'ai besoin de vos compétences
eh bien
abb raté j'ai promis de la ramener à sa
mère vous avez fait une promesse un
dinosaure oui pourquoi
tout le monde s'accroche à son voisin
dis moi c'est pas vrai
c'est quoi c'est le plus grand carnivore
que la terre ait porté
tu veux on s'en sort bien
[Musique]